Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Jessica, thanks for coming on with me.
I appreciate you being here.
Thank you so much Ryan, I appreciate you inviting me.
For sure.
So for those who don't know, Jessica goes by the handle on social media, the Combat
Midwife.
She is both, and you can correct me if I'm wrong here, but you're a paramedic and also
a midwife.
Yes.
And you do content and education based on helping teach both paramedics and lay people
how to work in women's health.
Yeah, so my background in education is teaching the military and I have been doing that for
years.
So I've taken my lessons learned from teaching those great guys and gals, and I have kind
of turned it into a really awesome workshop for people of all backgrounds, whether it's
law enforcement, EMS, layperson, someone that's going to be working overseas and kind of filling
in the gap of women and children's healthcare education since that's a huge deficit in all
aspects of medicine.
And how did you end up where you are?
Did you start as a paramedic and then transition into midwifery or the other way around?
How did it work?
EMS was first, but my desire to deliver babies was before that.
I kind of had a very, a personality first born daughter, a midlife crisis at like 12.
And so I kind of freaked out and went, what if I go through medical school and I can't
stand blood?
Because I knew that you don't really touch humans until much later on in medical school.
And so I had uncles that were firefighters and they said, if you can become a firefighter
and a medic, you can do anything.
So that's what I did in high school.
So I had a great career.
It started in high school working for the fire department in my area that provided EMS.
And then I was headhunted by the military when we went to war and they said, hey, we
need some instructors to teach the combat medic course.
And I had no idea what that was, but I have a rule that's still in place today.
And that is always say yes to an interview because you never know what type of relationship
you're going to cultivate with that experience.
And so I said yes and got hired on the spot and started, that was a Friday and started
on a Monday and the rest is kind of history.
Right on.
So did you teach for the military, but are you also in the military or is it separate?
No, so I'm a civilian instructor.
Okay, awesome.
And you're still actively teaching for the military at the moment, right?
Right.
Cool.
So are there specific courses or curriculum that you that you work with or is it more
based on like specific needs that come up within groups within the military?
A little of both.
So it's everything from initial education, recertification and pre-deployment needs,
depending on what's going on in the medic community for either special warfare, ground,
flight.
So I've taught everything from the whiskeys to the flight medics to special operations.
So it kind of depends on what's going on in the, you know, whatever skirmish we're involved
in at the time that that kind of dictates a lot of the education.
But I've taught those entire programs.
I just happened to be a midwife.
And so my specialty is women and children's health care in austere environments.
However, I mean, if you want to go over, you know, sonography or or throwing in some
chest tubes, we can do that too.
Right.
So it's important to know how all of those skills, even if that's not your specialty,
because you never know when you're going to need them.
For sure.
And then I think most of the folks who listen to this probably are familiar with the pathway
for the ems side of things.
But how does the path work for midwifery?
Like how does one go about becoming a midwife?
Oh, so I wrote an entire article for ems world because that's a common question in ems where
they're not quite sure what that even looks like.
But believe it or not, there's so many similarities between the ems creation, right?
And the midwifery.
There's always been around.
There's always been someone that's been the medical person in a community, whether that's
a tribe or or modern day, right?
There's always been someone that's kind of worn that hat and midwifery is the same way.
So we've always been around in the United States.
There are three different pathways to becoming a midwife.
And in the rest of the world, there's one with the US likes to make things a little
complicated.
So there's two non nursing pathways and there's one nursing pathway.
So I happen to have taken the one where I have a medical background in something else.
So I had a lot of that foundation already and I just wanted to, you know, become a midwife.
And then there's the I don't have a background in medicine at all.
And you can take that pathway.
And then otherwise you can do the nursing route.
I just never wanted to work in a hospital.
I have a paramedic heart, right?
And you don't really want me in a brick and mortar building.
That's just not my personality.
And so I prefer to be outside of the hospital.
So I'm familiar with working in birth centers, home births, and even I worked in refugee
camps.
I've done work as a midwife for natural disasters and a whole host of other fun things.
Awesome.
Fun for us, not fun for them.
Yeah, I can relate.
Yeah.
So can we talk a little bit about that?
Like the humanitarian and international medicine that you have done in the past or that you
do?
Yeah.
So I worked when Afghanistan fell in August of 21.
And when we pulled out of Afghanistan, there was a measure to bring those that have helped
us in the past over to the United States.
So there's a huge process with that.
And so the military and the government didn't realize that there might be women and children
and there also might be women that are pregnant.
So I got a phone call in the middle of the night from actually one of my previous soldiers.
And he said, hey, do you know anybody who can set up a women and children's tent?
Like yesterday?
And I went, yeah.
They're talking to the person that can do that.
He goes, well, I thought you might be already on a mission.
I was like, I actually am between things.
What do you need?
And he goes, well, we have a bunch of pregnant women.
We don't really know how to take care of them.
So I packed up and met them out there to take care of that situation.
So we had over 1500 pregnant women to care for.
And that's before we could place them wherever they were going to be living in the United
States.
Right.
That's a big process to bring in a lot of people and then also place them in different
states on where they were going to be living.
So that's not something you can just do overnight.
So I was working in kind of a holding pattern situation.
So they still have to get care and some of them were going to have babies and they did.
And some of them are going to have breastfeeding problems and babies with anomalies and all
sorts of stuff.
So it was it was kind of it was it was exciting.
And it was great to be on the other side of military medicine.
Right.
I send out a lot of guys to do death and destruction.
So it was kind of nice to be on the flip side of that and and providing that community with
care and love and resources.
And that was that specific experience.
That was when that was stateside once people were coming over after we had that good amount.
OK.
Right.
And everybody thinks, oh, you had a ton of resources.
So it's really not a humanitarian mission.
And I beg to differ.
We had no running water.
So I had to do pelvic exams, cervical checks.
And I had no running water.
So my nurse is like dousing me with bottles of water so I can wash my hands so I can go
to the next patient.
We had intermittent electricity.
We hardly ever had heat.
We were.
So yeah, we may have been in the United States, but it was absolutely a FEMA camp.
Like there was nothing.
There was no resources.
I had to be very creative with how to get treat things like preeclampsia and all sorts
of different stuff.
I just didn't have resources.
I barely had access to meds.
I did do a DNC on somebody with no pain medication that was catastrophic.
It was it was horrible.
Yeah, that's interesting.
I think you and I must have just barely missed one another because I was kind of tied up
in something similar.
And then the group that I was working with on the overseas side, they sent a bunch of
people to help facilitate intakes for just like general practice stuff.
Oh, sure.
But I didn't end up going.
I'm just it didn't it didn't work out when I came back home to the States.
That's interesting that maybe we would have met in the past at some point.
We probably would have.
Yeah, things had aligned just slightly differently.
Absolutely.
It's EMS is a very small world and medicine is a very small world, especially if you if
you fit in this austere kind of grid down type of it's a very it's a very tight knit
community that fit in this category.
Yeah, the more I've like worked in the international and humanitarian medicine space,
like I keep running into the same faces over and over.
For sure.
Yeah, it takes a long time.
Well, at least for me, it took like a long time to get myself into the fold, into the
network. But like now that I'm here, like I do run into a lot of the same people all
over the world, which is cool.
That is super cool.
Yeah, it's nice to see a familiar face when you're in an entirely different country.
For sure.
And then one one other thing in general, before we dive into some specific clinical
things that I wanted to ask you about is you do some like teaching and you've designed a
couple of courses and I understand you're coming out with a book before too long.
We'll circle back around to this at the end because I don't want people to like to miss
that. But do you want to talk about that just a bit before we dive in?
Yeah, so I recognize in military medicine and EMS that we have a kind of a mentality of
just drive faster or just take them to the hospital.
And that's a really bad mindset for any patient.
But specifically, when we're talking about women and children, because we are going to
come in contact with them, we are going to treat them whether that's in a major metropolitan
area and you have all the resources available at your fingertips or or you're in a rural
area of the United States or you're overseas, you are going to 50 percent of the population
is female. You're going to see them and their childbearing age is wide and varying.
And there's a plethora of different situations that can transpire during a woman's lifespan,
whether it is pregnancy related or not.
And so the whole mindset of if there's abdominal situations and it's a female, just drive
fast. The hospital is really poor medicine on our part.
And it's really awful for the patient because they're thinking that we're going to know
what to do.
And then we have this mentality of just pack them up and go because I don't want to do
it like it's a game of hot potato.
I just think that's really poor medicine and it's just awful experience for the patient.
So kind of getting over our fear of OBGYN calls and just dealing with them by having the
best knowledge possible.
And so that's that's kind of the conception of the combat midwife course is really all
about starting at this is what a menstrual cycle is and that and why is it important to
know what that is?
Well, because it dictates the outcome of labor, it dictates her cycle, it dictates how she's
going to respond to medication and a whole bunch of other things.
So we go all the way through the first year of a baby's life and some things that can
go right and wrong and everything in between.
So it's an all day, hands on, really fun class.
I bring mannequins, we get our hands dirty.
There's, you know, the fake blood scenario based education.
And so you can kind of walk away going, yeah, I may never want to see a patient like that.
Like that's not my that's not my bread and butter.
And I don't really enjoy those calls.
I'm more of a trauma person or I really love cardiology or I really love respiratory calls.
That's great.
You can have your bread and butter, but you should be able to know how to do those skills.
I don't really enjoy doing crikes.
They're not my favorite thing.
I don't I don't love them.
But I know how to do it and I practice those skills because should I need to know how to
do that?
You'd want me to be able to be accountable for that.
Right.
So I understand that not everybody loves OBGYN or pediatrics, but you should be able to know
how to handle those calls and not do so in fear.
And that's what happens in EMS is we just get planted these little seeds of fear of
oh, kids compensate until they just don't write.
Like I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
Like, well, how is that helpful information to me?
That's that's not a resource.
That's nothing but practicing medicine based in fear.
And I'd like to just get rid of that.
So the whole goal is to squash all of those silly little jingles that we've all been told
our whole career, get rid of them and and put in the appropriate information that's actually
beneficial.
And whether you're stateside or overseas, you will walk away feeling like, wow, I can
totally handle this now.
Yeah.
And then is the the course that you teach the combat midlife course, is that specific
for EMS providers or is it more generalized?
Absolutely anyone can and should take this class.
So when people sign up, I always ask if you're a health care professional.
That way I know to talk about the TXA, right, or lab eta law.
Right.
So I throw all of that stuff in and you can walk away with your CEOs.
It's kind of cool.
Awesome.
Cool.
Yeah.
Well, like I said, we'll mention that again at the end in case people are interested in
like looking more into that or potentially taking it.
We can also do that.
But I had a couple clinical things I wanted to talk about if so we can make a little transition
here.
So one of the reasons why we got in touch is because I heard you on I think it was
the prolonged field care podcast.
Yeah.
Talking about postpartum hemorrhage.
And that's one thing that we spend a decent amount of time talking about in transport
like on the EMS side or in critical care transport in general.
So I'll make sure we put a link to that in case people are interested on that subject.
So that kind of reminded me that years ago I kind of put together this like a field reference
guide or a protocol for an agency that I was working for.
And one of the things that we covered was like how to facilitate an abnormal delivery.
So I think my impression is that most EMS clinicians can manage fairly well like with
a straightforward delivery.
Like we know how to keep the baby warm.
We know how to do an assessment.
We can like resuscitate baby fairly well, mom sometimes depending on how bad things
are.
But when things get weird when we have like a breach delivery or like a shoulder dystocia
things like that, that's kind of where at least in my impression like our ability to
manage things sort of breaks down and kind of pushes us to just drive fast.
That's not always an option.
In the setting where I was working when I put this protocol set together that wasn't
always available to us.
So I was trying to like rethink of like how we present like different maneuvers and like
ways to facilitate a more complicated delivery.
And the way that I found which I don't know how well it worked out was instead of like
doing text based descriptions of like these different maneuvers which is like I find pretty
hard to like wrap my mind around.
I came across this free reference online called the Alarm or textbook which has like
very simple sketches of all these different maneuvers to facilitate delivery.
So I kind of like embedded those into our protocol.
And that was you know that was years ago like I don't know maybe like 2018 2019.
And I never did come across someone who I would consider like a subject matter expert
in that field to ask about who has experience like you do in both the pre hospital setting
and in on the delivery and like the OBGYN side of things.
So that's how we got in touch as I just reached out and was like hey what do you think about
this and maybe we could spend some time talking about it on a podcast.
But with that kind of as the framework what are your thoughts about like this in general
like how we present and how we prepare EMS providers to deal with complicated deliveries
in the field.
So your question is how should we prepare EMS providers to be ready for complications.
Yeah I guess that's part of it and the other part is just like what is your impression
of like how we already do it.
And then I imagine you might have a proposal for how to do it better.
Yeah so how we're currently doing it is very fear based and is the drive fast model instead
of really diving into.
I mean we EMS education spends less than 2 percent on women's health in their entire
education.
So that's just a disservice already at the beginning.
We're not spending enough time talking about these things.
And instead of looking at the woman's life cycle as a whole and going these are the complications
that can arise and these are the variations and normal.
We just kind of lump everything into oh it's OBJEN and we'll just we're going past the
ER we're going straight to the fifth floor.
Right.
Like everybody just kind of focuses on that rather than going OK let's just do our normal
differentials.
Let's gather all of our information like we would with any other patient again whether
it's a cardiac or nothing just a sick call.
Right.
We'd have no idea it's a sick call patient.
We don't know what the heck's going on.
We have nothing but a variety of really weird symptoms and signs.
Let's go through them.
So we really need to go back to the beginning and back to the basics like we would with
any other patient and gather all the data and all the information because a lot of times
there's things we can do and resources we have on our ambulance.
We just aren't thinking that far in advance because we're going oh my God not not women
problems.
I don't want to do that.
So I think that's kind of the overall are there education systems out there that probably
do a really great job.
Yes I would assume there are.
I obviously don't know every school in the nation.
Right.
So I obviously don't know that there's some awesome school system that's spending a lot
of time.
But the other thing is that birth in general in America is very fear based.
If you go to any other country and you kind of dip into what their thought process on
on labor delivery birth postpartum breastfeeding it's just a normal physiological process
that takes place in a woman's life.
That's not our mentality in the states.
Everything's catastrophic.
The whole world is on fire.
Everyone's dying is normally our thought process when it comes to those things.
Coming from the midwifery side of stuff we always think that birth postpartum labor everything
is normal until it's not.
So this is all normal stuff until it proves that it is no longer normal.
So having that same mentality just like we would with any other patient is super important.
And then how do we fix that.
Well we've kind of got to get rid of a lot of the silly things that have been hanging
around in our textbooks since Nancy Caroline wrote the first one.
Right.
Like let's get rid of keeping the baby level with the vagina until the cord stops pulsating.
Why is that still in there.
There's no physiological reason for that to be there.
As soon as baby's born baby needs to go straight to mom and you need to stop touching them.
Leave them alone.
Or the whole clamping and cutting the cord right away.
Leave the cord alone.
It is giving the baby oxygen.
So if the baby's struggling to transition from being an underwater creature to a land
creature then we need to keep those two together.
The cord will stop pulsating because the placenta has received the appropriate hormonal exchange
that transpires that says I no longer need you.
I'm good.
I got this breathing thing down and it will shut down on its own.
Leave it be.
And to be very honest I even as a midwife I never clamp and cut the cord until way after
the placenta is delivered even hours after because I want every drop of blood that's
in that placenta to go to that baby.
So we don't have a baby with less red blood cells than they're supposed to have.
Right.
And so that's really important.
So just kind of getting rid of some of those really silly things that have been hanging
around an EMS for God knows why.
Trust me I've written all the textbooks multiple times to say can you please get rid of these
things and here's why.
But they just hang on.
And they again they're back to planting those seeds of fear and mistrust.
Like we're not trusting ourselves as EMS providers anymore.
If we're going oh my God everything's on fire.
Yeah that makes sense.
Yeah I wonder if maybe the like the origin or the original motive for that is to like
separate the two things.
You know now you have like one patient over here and one patient over here.
Yeah I mean we teach the same where they teach the same in hospital settings as well.
Yeah they do.
But the United States ranks really low for mother and maternal mortality rates.
Like we have we have we rank 60th.
That means there's 59 other countries that have better mother and baby outcomes.
We rank last out of all the top 10 industrialized nations.
That's not something to write home about.
That's awful.
If you look at the 59 other countries that have better outcomes a lot of those would
be considered third world countries.
So the next question you should be asking is well why.
Why is the United States ranking so horribly.
The answer is we push obstetric care rather than midwifery care.
So every other country that is ranking better than us their primary care provider for obstetrics
is going to be a midwife.
So that's someone that is specifically honed in on what is normal versus what is abnormal.
An obstetric physician is a surgeon.
Their goal is to get babies out as quickly as possible.
It's not to sit there and labor with a mom when everything is going right.
Yeah that makes sense.
Do you think this is well we'll get back on track with the questions that I had in a moment.
But do you think that is changing in any particular direction.
Do you think it's getting better getting worse in general in this moment.
Is the United States going to have better outcomes in the following years is that what
you're asking me.
More about the focus on midwifery versus obstetrics.
My impression is that it varies a lot depending on where in the country you are.
I see a little bit more of a focus on like home births and midwifery in like my limited
exposure to that side of things.
But I didn't know if that was like if that's nationwide or if that's just in my niche where
I live.
Yeah so there are particular pockets in the country that do seem more out of hospital
birth or midwifery care than obstetric care.
So that would be things like pardon me California Oregon Washington some of the Intermountain
West states for sure.
I think a lot of that has to do with the fact that those those states were very rural for
a really long time and you needed community care and midwives are all about providing
care in a community.
So kind of think back to the little black bag and a horse right.
The way doctors used to practice.
So I think a lot of that has to do with that set up.
But when we look at the nation I did a post about this a couple maybe last week about
how the United States is experiencing a huge deficit in obstetric care providers.
That's everybody across the board.
So that's physicians midwives of all flavor and color.
And we have huge pockets of obstetric provider deserts in the United States.
We need more care providers.
We need more midwives.
I don't think in my time frame on this planet I will see more midwifery care in a drastic
sense where we're hovering at about 2 percent in the United States are out of hospital births
that there was a significant increase during the covid time frame.
And that has a lot to do with hospitals saying just drop your wife off at the front door
you can see her in three days and dads were like pound sand.
I'm not you're that's a you kidding right.
I'm not doing that.
I'm not just leaving her to labor and deliver on her own.
That's insanity.
So all of us midwives are our phones were ringing off the hook with a lot of late term
transfers which was beautiful and that has sparked a fire because a lot of women have
been like why was I doing it that way.
That's awful.
I'll just have the rest of my kids with a midwife.
So that has created a huge surge but it has a lot to do with in the early nineteen hundreds
late late eighteen hundreds early nineteen hundreds when the Rockefellers kind of took
over all of the education for physicians.
They realized that they were missing out on 50 percent of the population and so they created
a huge smear campaign.
You can look this up.
I'm not making it up.
You can look up wanted posters for midwives on the Internet.
They still exist and you can see how the education system and hospitals were describing
midwives as dirty uneducated minorities immigrants et cetera just really awful slanderous things
that I'm not going to repeat but you can look them up yourself and that has really stuck.
So we've we've imprinted on the culture and the community as a whole of that's dangerous.
So don't do that.
And the only way you're going to get really good care is in the hospital and the outcomes
for babies and moms has drastically decreased as the years have progressed of us having
more and more women have babies in the hospital.
In fact if you look at the 1970s the C-section rate went up exponentially when we introduced
the TOCO monitor.
So that's the fetal monitor that stays on mom the whole time she's in the hospital.
So when we introduced that the C-section rate skyrocketed.
However it did not change the outcome of mother and baby mortality rates and a positive it
changed it in a negative.
So we're not doing things in the states that are actually really beneficial.
Yeah I have I have a few follow-up points and questions on that.
One is that I think I think the way that you describe it in that like you either have
birth in a hospital with a physician or you have birth at home kind of on your own maybe
with a midwife that is often like how people think about it.
But there is there are my understanding is there is like a middle ground there are like
birthing centers where you can like have like you can deliver with a midwife and also have
like the support of a like a greater staff if there is the need for that.
Do you have thoughts on that or experience with that?
Yes I've worked in several birth centers and there's really no difference between a birth
center and home.
Everything that's inside of a birth center is going to be in your home.
So if you if you want to pay extra money for a facility fee and in a newborn fee that's
great knock yourself out that's perfect.
But everything that's in that room it's just pretty it's just a pretty space.
So if you if you really want to go somewhere to have a baby that's cool that those are
options but I don't know about you when I don't feel good I want to be in my own clothes
I want to I want to be in my own bathtub in my own bed I want to eat my own food I want
to sit on my own couch but that's me that doesn't have to be for everyone and there
are lots of people that love birth centers because maybe they live really far from their
midwife and so it's a way for them to come into town you know a few weeks before stay
at an Airbnb do a babymoon you know kind of hang out for a little bit and eventually have
a baby and eventually go home.
So I've I've worked at birth centers before and those are really great fits for maybe
those types of people and I get that and there's other people that just really have it ingrained
in their head that they must go somewhere to have a baby and that's fine too.
That's just not my cup of tea I would prefer to be in my own robe at my own house.
So I love home birth my favorite part of home birth is tucking the whole family into bed
and saying bye bye I'll see you in the morning.
That's my favorite part is being able to go that was a really great birth I cleaned your
whole house up I put a meal in the oven because I always do that and if there's older kids
siblings I make a birthday cake because it's great for kids and bonding and then you know
you wake up and there's a stew on the stove that's all ready for you and you're in your
own place you're in your own stuff a lot of people love that other people just they really
want to go to a birth center but there's nothing different between a hospital a birth center
or home regarding the stuffs in the labor and delivery room there's literally no difference
I have all of the same things the only thing that's different from those two out of hospital
options is a surgical team however we are experiencing a tremendous desert of obstetric
care there are many hospitals that are shutting down their entire OB unit they don't even
have somebody on standby to do a c-section.
Yeah my I guess I have two more follow-up questions might take us out of order but that's
okay my my first one was how do you see you think there's a role for EMS providers to like
facilitate a mother's like comfort with delivering at home like if for example let's say there's
like a community paramedicine program in some rural community and those EMS providers have
been through a course like yours or have like above average level of knowledge with like
helping facilitate delivery I think there's a role for them to keep those births at home
or to help facilitate that process in any way. Well my course doesn't turn you into a midwife
in eight hours for sure so that I mean there's gonna be a huge huge deficit in just understanding
kind of women's health in general for long term or for prolonged I'm not really sure I guess I'm
not I'm not sure what what they're what you're envisioning their role to be. Yeah I guess I guess
my that's a good question I guess my understanding is that like many times my impression is that
folks are hesitant to deliver at home because like what if something happens like let's say I have
a midwife who is on club what if she is too far away or what if weather prevents her from getting
here whereas that decision may be impacted somewhat if you know that like the the EMS providers who
always have access to get to you have some higher level of training. Right okay so I think what
the real question there is is how do midwives handle emergencies? Yeah I mean I think it's
different if if a midwife is physically present there versus if they're like not able to and I
think they're not able to be their part is what my impression is that what that's what scares people.
Yeah maybe my understanding is maybe my understanding of that is off a little bit. Yeah I think we're
gonna I think I'm gonna help answer that question that is really good planning like I don't take
patients that are five hours from me that that's that's not gonna work right I mean I've had I've
had previous clients reach out to me and want me to deliver their second third fourth fifth baby or
what because they want to have all their babies with me that's just as some some mamas really love
that and and they don't live in the same state as me anymore so I have flown and hung out there
and we just wait for a baby to be born right and I live in their guest room until that baby comes
so really a really good plan should be set up. I've only missed one baby ever in my whole career
and that's because the little thing just came super fast I mean I was I pulled in and dad's
still holding the baby you know like we we little one was just born those births that happen super
duper fast they're the easiest births ever there's going to not be a problem it I just I've delivered
enough babies that that's just and statistically there's lots of papers that are done on precipitous
births are super easy birth there's no problems they just pop out because they just pop out so
there aren't any issues but yeah having a really good plan in place on on what's going on and then
as a midwife it's my job to educate the family on what to do if I'm not there I mean
I have broken laws to get to my families okay so like it's not it's not going I'm not going to
just not show up right um there's Texas is known for getting really bad winters every so many years
right and um the entire city was shut down and I moved the barricades and put drove through put
them back and drove some more to go to that mama I wasn't going to just not show up because it was
inconvenient and super icy and I basically slid the whole way there right like I'm not going to
just leave her so having a really good plan and then also feeling like your midwife is on is part
of your birth team I can only speak for myself I can't speak for every midwife in the whole world
for sure and then my my other question is you mentioned that the difference between
the home birth birthing center and then the hospital delivery is surgical capacity
um how often like is that actually needed right that's a great question so the world health
organization has a great area on their website where they will actually show you it's a really
it's a really cool interactive graph and you can see it on the world health organization's website
you go to their obstetric tab and you can see uh nations that report births over decades there's
decades and decades of information that you can go back if you just really want to nerd out on a
friday night because you have nothing better to do you can totally do that um and you can look at
outcomes but they specifically say that less than 10 percent of all births worldwide that's the whole
world should ever need intervention and out of that 10 1 should be a c-section rate the united
states has over a 50 percent c-section rate in many states like new york uh there there's just
that's insanity so the national average is 35 percent for the united states so we're already
really really high but there are several multiple states in the union where it's way over 50 percent
c-section rates you cannot tell me that 50 percent of the female population is just broken
and they don't know how to birth babies but that that's not math thing correctly
right yeah that makes sense and that was kind of my yeah my understanding of the situation is that
we we default to surgical intervention probably a lot more often than we need to sure and the thing
is is that there are signs so in example if we're at home and i'm your midwife i'm not just going to
all of us suddenly go ah we have to have a c-section right now everyone's dying the whole world is on
fire no there's tons of signs and i'm collecting that data and i'm distributing it to the family
going okay so we were supposed to be going on a straight and narrow and we veered to the left now
so now we need to talk about what our options are the times that we need emergency cesareans
are very sick moms such as she was just in a car accident she's bleeding internally and i'm so happy
that there's a you know an ems helicopter that can get her to a level one trauma center that has
a NICU and we can take care of everybody that's when we're super happy like trauma is the bomb
in the united states right like we really are very good at that and so in situations like that
yeah i'm super happy there's a c-section option because then mom and baby are going to walk out
of that hospital alive and able to have a really great life i'm that's super awesome but things
like breach twins none of those are are c-section necessitated that none i've delivered all of those
guys at home yeah yeah that's something that kind of brings us back to where we where we started
is that something that you cover in your in your course when you teach folks in the combat mid-wife
is like different techniques for managing like a complicated or breach delivery absolutely yeah
for sure a lot of it has to do with positioning the mama so in our head we think that moms need
to be flat on their back with their you know legs up in stirrups in order to have babies
and that's the worst position possible and that position stems all the way back to a really gross
king in england he doesn't need to be mentioned because he's a sicko but he wanted his entire
you know all of his little minions to watch all of his wives and concubines have babies so he
said that they needed to lay flat on their back so everybody could have a front row seat
to the action and that just really stuck because it does make it super easy for the provider trust
me i don't love crouching down in the catcher position right and and it hurts my back hurts
my shoulders hurt my arms it's not comfortable but it is the best position for mom to be in when
she's in a squatting or kneeling or hands and knees because it enables the pelvis to open fully
both at the inlet and the outlet in order for baby to pass the easiest and so things like
breach complication shoulder dystocia that has everything to do with positioning with mom
so once you get them in the correct position you'll you'll eliminate the the need for all of those
yeah and a lot of those maneuvers that we teach are like with mom in uh like a supine position
so the idea is like if we get her out of that position to begin with we can
maybe avoid having to to use those maneuvers
and hey just as a quick aside we've mentioned these maneuvers a couple times but we never really
got into the specifics of what they are so examples of these would be the mick roberts
maneuver for shoulder dystocia or a love set maneuver for a breach delivery things like that
you can learn more about those in the references cited in the show notes
so even helper right which comes from like advanced life support for obstetrics or if you
want to a lot of schools are kind of pulling from that helper mnemonic for for shoulder dystocia
right and it is all about mom being flat on her back and i'm going to tell you right now if you
just get her off her butt you're you're going to open up that that pelvis in a way where you're
going to be able to actually facilitate delivery or perform that maneuver much easier and it will
be that more successful so the best thing to do is have her on hands and knees and put her in a
running start so that's you know knees at a 90 degree angle one forward one back as if you were
at the starting point of running a race right and your foot is going to be on the foot block
and then shifting those i usually count to three and make her shift count to three and make her
shift and i just tell her to kind of get into that position of moving because what you're going to do
shoulder dystocia is a shoulder problem and it's an inlet issue it's not an outlet issue
so if you go over helper the e is evaluated for an episiotomy we don't have an outlet problem
the shoulder is hung up on her pelvis we need to get the shoulder underneath it and again if you
can just get her shimmied and up off her butt that pelvis is going to open and baby's going to drop
every time and you find that you're often able to do that just with mom shifting her position of
her her pelvis and you don't even have to use like manual pressure on the shoulder anything like that
yourself no i've never um you're talking about the super pubic rocking you you could do that if if
because i'm palpating baby as baby's moving down right like i've got my hand i i'm very good at
going oh that's a butt that's a head that's a left shoulder that's a because that's what i
practiced in all of my years of education right like we we're very good at palpating babies
so i can figure out the position that baby's in and kind of pick my maneuvers that's not something
that the average ems person is going to be very skilled and knowledgeable on and i get that so
that's what i'm just trying to make it really easy and if you can just get her on hands and
knees and have her shimmy and i usually make dad count to three shift to me count to three shift
a knee and have them just kind of keep repeating that in their head and that gives dad something
to do or the firefighter or your partner i kind of want my partner for me right you know that's
we kind of do but give somebody that job and then we just kind of focus on watching the baby pass
through the birth canal and and that turtle sign should go away of when they present you know it's
a really bad texas two step it's two steps forward and like three steps backwards that's not a texas
two step so you want to make sure that they're moving in a positive direction and once you get
her off her tush that usually these resolve very very quickly and do you think there's value in like
teaching like all these different named maneuvers to ems providers like the way that we tend to do
it in like ob gyn like continuing education offerings or do you think like not understanding
them fully or not having the opportunity to practice them in real life do you think it
potentially like does more harm than good so anything we don't okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna
kind of flip the script everybody loves to ask the question what's the best tourniquet in the world
like what's the best tourniquet to use and my answer is the one that you have on you and the
one you know how to use totally right so the the answer to your question is i can throw mnemonics
and acronyms at you all day long but if they don't register in your brain if you're having a
hard time understanding them if you haven't used them in a really long time it's pretty useless
it's not it's not going to be very helpful however if you have a really good foundation you know how
to use it you've practiced it a lot in school or in our ceu class and you have a good grasp on it
sometimes those are really really helpful for recall when shit has hit the fan right like
everything is blowing up in your face and you're like oh it's three o'clock in the morning i haven't
peed in four hours and i have 15 you know run forms to write and oh my gosh now i have this
that's a lot that's a lot of pressure a lot of pressure to perform it can cause a lot of anxiety
and i think that those are very helpful for even other types of calls right even things like
cardiac arrest having all of those acronyms and mnemonics if they create that muscle memory
you can hear that still small voice of your instructor or your mentor or someone that's
really close to you that you look up to kind of whispering all those things in your head and it is
really helpful um but again it's absolutely utterly useless if we're not practicing those things if
if they're not creating that muscle memory then they're really not helpful at all yeah and what are
your thoughts on there are some mannequins now like some high fidelity sims that we use that's
they actually have like pressure sensors in them so that when you practice some of these maneuvers
it actually yes it either works or it doesn't do you like what are your what are your thoughts on
that um okay so i you i bring mannequins with me to my for my workshop um but i'm using the
laredalls um what do they call her oh mama berthy i think is her name and so i love that that
particular mannequin was created specifically for overseas low resource training that that is that
entire mannequins purpose so i have those and i bring those with me and i love them the reason i
like them is because they're low tech i'm not worried about things like sensors plugging in
the wi-fi connecting and they fit in backpacks that i can just jump on a plane and fly to mexico
teach a class and leave right so i don't have to worry about a pelican box making it or not making
it right so i love those the i have used almost i think every one of the cool high fidelity
mannequins out there and they are really really great but they do have some downfalls just like
every high fidelity mannequin out there and that is if you don't have somebody that knows how to
really work the the product you can run into it's just a really beautiful paper weight
and that that can be really frustrating when you're someone who wants to really dive into
whatever you're learning that day so the military had mom and natalie for a really long time and
used her for a really long time i liked that mannequin i thought that it did a very good job
for normal birth and i thought it did a really great job overall for breach shoulder dystocia
not not so much and i wound up just utilizing because the mannequin i used today didn't exist
back in the day but when i was teaching the 68 whiskeys i wound up just pulling out a pelvis
and then a soft baby right my from my own stash of education models and i wound up just teaching
it that way so that way you could actually visualize the pelvis getting you know and the
shoulder not matching correctly and going oh now i understand why i'm doing these particular hand
movements all of that to say i think high tech and high fidelity has its place however i don't
think that we should always rely on it sometimes analog is super awesome and really fills in the
gap and creates a really great learning experience i know that high fidelity is so
in right now because you can push a lot of people through very quickly but i'm not that type of
educator i keep my classes in my workshop very small for a very particular reason i want everyone
to feel like they got hands-on with me that day and i don't want somebody to walk away going
okay that was a lot of bells and whistles but i don't know that i really took a lot away from that
that's just how i teach um but again i think i think high fidelity has its place i just think
that and i'm i'm an analog girl in general um but i just think that analog has its place you know
just low tech type of stuff yeah that makes sense okay i want to switch gears and ask you another
about another clinical concept that we talk about a lot in management of the obstetric patients
and that's the idea of intrauterine resuscitation so you mentioned before like the clinical scenario
where you have a mother who was in a car accident and now needs to be like emergently evacuated
to a facility that is both the trauma center and also has NICU capabilities right we often like
this is like something that like exists at the bottom of our ems algorithms it's like
do this thing called intrauterine resuscitation like save mom save baby right and we talk a little
bit about like the specifics of that like you know what it is when do we do it how do we go about it
that sort of thing it's at the bottom of our algorithm because we hope we don't get that far
fair right we we hope everything else before that works maybe just to like talk about the
idea in general so my understanding of this concept of like intrauterine resuscitation
is like doing all of your like trauma management stuff to keep mother alive and well so that the
baby has the maximum potential for survival as well absolutely so everything from oxygen
positioning right left lateral recumbent or elevating the pelvis if we're dealing with
bleeding or we're dealing with maybe we have a seizure patient maybe we have a mom who has a
seizure condition and she happens to be pregnant right that we want to do all of the same seizure
things that we would normally do and our normal treatment plan because if we if we can save mom
that increases the likelihood that we're going to save baby does it always work that way no
we live in a we live in a broken world but the likelihood is going to be exponential so yes focus
on mom when mom and baby are one unit because if you can resuscitate mom your your your side quest
is you know saving baby yeah makes sense just another transition here we got onto the subject
of postpartum hemorrhage and the idea of using a either a Foley catheter or a specifically
designed catheter to treat postpartum hemorrhage so if you want to learn more about that you can
take a look at an article in the show notes about this specific type of catheter
um so I don't I don't know a ton of agencies out there that have the foley's maybe you are more
familiar with that than than I am I just I personally haven't worked anywhere that has
that carries those and I don't I don't know a lot of agencies that do they are really great devices
when they're used for a patient that actually needs them I think going back to what causes
bleeding in pregnancy and understanding that physiological process is super helpful
so if we're talking about pregnancy and postpartum postpartum hemorrhage is the number one killer
of women postpartum all in all countries and it has everything to do with mismanagement of labor
and delivery and mismanagement of the placenta a teeny tiny portion is thrombin related so think of
blood cascading factors that we just probably didn't even know about and that patient was going
to crash on us no matter what even if we have all the bells and whistles right whether inside or
outside of the hospital because they have a blood clotting problem so kind of outside of my scope
right probably yours too so in those situations you know we need things like platelets and blood
and a whole bunch of other stuff that we just typically don't have
but mismanagement of labor so pulling on things speeding things up using pitotin for augmentation
pulling the placenta out before it needs to come out those are all going to significantly increase
your hemorrhage potential after birth then if we look at pre pre delivery that's things like
miscarriages fetal demise so again that could be pregnancy related or it could be trauma related
it could be pharmaceutical related right prescribed or or street pharmacy it could also be things like
miscarriage so we're dealing with someone who's that is labor we need to we need to understand
that a miscarriage she is going through labor the baby's just smaller right so she's going to go
through the entire same hormonal shift process she's going to be at risk for postpartum hemorrhage
she's going to be at risk for postpartum uh pre-eclampsia any clampsia so we need to be thinking
that way even if it is just a miscarriage and i'm using air quotes for those that can't see me so
switching our thought process and our our brains for understanding again what the physiological
process is is going to help us and then from there knowing what our tools are right so if
we're dealing with someone who's bleeding and it's eclampsia related we'll fix the dang blood pressure
right we're gonna if we fix the dang blood pressure the bleeding is going to stop
right so if it's trauma related or postpartum hemorrhage then TXA is going to fix the problem
because you don't have to learn a new measurement right you have to learn any new drug distribution
on that it's the same dosing so whatever you're doing for a trauma non-pregnant person you can do
for postpartum hemorrhage or trauma pregnant person so that's super awesome i like to not have to
memorize new meds or new doses right and so that those are the things that we should have
accessible to us i know more and more EMS agencies are carrying blood and that's awesome i'm a huge
proponent for that for sure because we know the outcomes for our patients are going to be better
the sooner they get blood products so if your patient meets the criteria and you have a protocol
for pregnant people and blood products that's awesome not everybody does um the other two things
i wanted to ask you about are more geared for folks who work in the critical care setting
so like critical care ground crews or flight crews um but we not all critical care crews have access
to token monitoring but a lot of us are trained in it and do like depending on like if we're on
a fixed wing or a truck versus on a helicopter right and that's something that we don't do
that often so i find that a lot of us rely on reference cards or cheat sheets or something
absolutely to manage like interpretation of those trips and i was just curious if you
your thoughts on that approach or if you have specific tips or any references or anything to
help us in in that realm uh yes so i use veal chop as a way to kind of remember um my variables
my d cells etc i'm assuming you got taught the same thing um and that kind of helps me remember
i use a cheat card too because sometimes when you're looking at squiggly lines or listening
to a doppler it's nice to have a card in your hand uh don't think that i don't use those just
because i'm i'm a midwife who's got a lot of births under her belt i i have all the same flipbooks
you guys carry they're in my side pockets of my scrubs or um you know my jump uniform or whatever
i'm doing so those are great i pull those out a lot and and use those to help me kind of go
through them but you know we're looking for a baby to respond cardiac wise when they're stimulated
so i like to take a baby grab a butt and kind of wiggle them and their heart rate should eventually
respond to that and come back down again that's great so we're looking at rate rhythm and quality
just like we are with any other human because if you kind of think that way you're going oh yeah
that that totally makes sense so yeah the rate is important i i want it to be you know 120 to 180
if i'm over 180 i'm thinking golly why is is mom in pain and so her her pulse is up so that's
going to make babies pulse up is there an underlining fever an underlining infection is there some sort
of pregnancy related infection right so bv yeast chircomonus something's going on there that are
a uti that's very asymptomatic in women in general and extra asymptomatic in pregnancy which is why
we test for it all the time so those things can cause the heart the heart rate to go up because
now we're dealing with sepsis right or the risk of that so just kind of thinking the same same
process with our our born patients is our our unborn patients they're kind of thinking the same
thought process and then using your cards because you don't do this all the time and the toco
monitor is great i just for for critical patience it makes sense to use those things i get that i
just tend to use intermittent monitoring with my doppler um so i can look at a particular window
right and i can listen to just that one to two minute time period because that's just the way
my brain kind of processes data and that's also the way i was trained is to use intermittent
monitoring and then repositioning patient just because we in we encourage left lateral
incumbent doesn't mean you shouldn't try sitting mom up or rotating her to the right or um you know
putting her on hands and knees if that is appropriate for your transport situation
you got to think kind of outside the box remember our patients don't read the textbook they don't
know how they're supposed to present and everybody's internal organs are a little bit funky
they're they're not going to follow all the rules all of the time i mean how many times have we
been on a cardiac patient who's a female and she didn't have any of those classic signs all the
time right so we need to be thinking that way for our pregnant mamas too and then um i think
around the time when i reached out to you to try and set something up i was i had i was working on
that same set of protocols that i talked about at the very beginning i had put together like a
cheat sheet for interpretation of like fetal heart tones like and the main part is like once
you identify i think like we're all like pretty decent if we have a cheat sheet like following
the algorithm and figuring out like what do we have the next step of that is like what do you do
if you find x y or z um so i kind of like put this like and i'll share in the show notes like a
document together to like guide folks through um that decision process but a lot of the information
i found i got from this free textbook um there's a website called open stacks that has a lot of
like free references uh and that was something i shared with you and i was curious if you had a
chance to to look and get your thoughts on that i did i looked over it again last night to have
it all fresh in my head for this morning and it is a really great resource and i do like the
pictures i thought those were extra helpful sometimes it's nice to see oh that's what you
meant okay because sometimes reading text you you're creating an image different than what
the author wanted you to do so i really liked the images i thought that was great
and i did love that it showed what a variable heart rate would look like on the toko monitor
i thought that that was really helpful i put those in my class as well um for especially
for ems providers because they need they need to know what that looks like um they might have a
doppler or they might have sonography on on their ambulance and so it's nice to know how to use those
tools while they're probably used to doing a fast exam or using the doppler for other types of
treatment plans it's kind of cool to be able to use that equipment for other stuff too so
having some knowledge base i thought it was great i loved the images i thought they were really good
cool yeah and i'll make sure i share a link to that because i similarly thought it was like
a pretty good reference and it's available for free which is rad totally rad i love it um you
mentioned also about um that some ems agencies now have access to sonography or point of care
ultrasound i was in a class this was through um i'm on a dmat team like a disaster medical
resistance team yeah and within that general framework for like you know our national response
to emergencies there is some like transport component as well and i was in a class years ago
with a woman who talked about a paper that had recently come out of the times this has probably
been like five or six years ago about coming up with like a point of care ultrasound like
algorithm of sorts for complicated labor to like determine if you had any um life threatening
emergencies that would warrant like you know diverting to a more appropriate facility and i
for the life of me like didn't keep track of the woman's name or ever managed to track down that
paper so i was curious if you either know the paper i'm referring to or in general have like
some sort of guidance for folks who do have access to ultrasound how we might like learn a little
bit more about applying that tool with our pregnant patients because like you said most of us are
trained more on the trauma side and some of us maybe have a little bit of exposure to like cardiac
ultrasound in cardiac arrest right that like beyond that most of our understanding of ultrasound
in the field is pretty limited but i do know there's an application i'm just not that familiar
with like where i would even go to like develop that skill set or to look further yeah okay so uh
right so i've had exposure to ultrasound in in the way you mentioned right so cardiac and trauma
it's on ems but especially the military because they love that right they they especially the
soft teams they they love using that type of tool for those situations but my foundation
in sonography is going to be with my midwife hat on and that's really it can be helpful information
but it should not be your sole data point and anything outside of the first trimester is pretty
useless information other than it's a boy or a girl and i would do 50 50 with that and then
what position maybe is what you're going to get in that information but third trimester is pretty
useless because you can't even get the full baby on the screen so it's really hard the only thing
i'm going to be able to identify is that a butt in the pelvis or is that a head but i can tell you
that just by palpit i don't need it i don't need it sonography yeah i guess i was thinking more of
like identifying complications like if you had um an abruption or placenta previa like these things
that we teach about in like in the critical care transport like these complications that would like
warrant the need for a surgical intervention like if they're yeah like my understanding is that
there is a way to like readily identify those types of complications not necessarily um to do
like the fetal sonography like you would in a follow-up ovi visit right right so yes you you
could theoretically identify placenta abruption or previa right because you're going to have fluid
behind the placenta with placental abruption um and you're going to have if if you can get the
placenta and the cervix in one sweep which that's that's a lot that would be that would be a that
would be a lot for an out of hospital sonography system to do i don't i don't know that it i'd
have to practice that myself and see if it could but you really should be treating your patient
based off of symptoms at that point fair yeah yeah so again it's a tool but it's in in those
critical situations such as placental abruption i could care less what the sonogram is telling
me because i'm going to go off of the blood pressures in the toilet right uh the patient
looks like a hot mess because i can see through her skin and um she's in and out of consciousness
i've got a ton of blood or i have an abdomen filling right because maybe baby is blocking
the cervix as they should be at that point and the blood's filling in the uterus and in the abdomen
so the abdomen's hard you know i can tap it and you've got that funk funk funk rather than the
thrill that you should have because if you tap a mama belly you should have that opposite wave
right you should feel the wave on the on the other hand but you're not getting that you're
getting thud thud thud that's telling me that there's fluid filling in whether it's amniotic
blood both i don't necessarily care at that point because i'm going to treat it all as if it's the
most catastrophic yeah that makes sense yeah i should maybe i should give it another try to track
down this paper because the way it was presented to me um it was like a five or six step like point
of care sonography for the pregnant patient to like identify life threats and like rule out those
surgical complications right so what you're saying is a fast type exam but it's for obstetrics i'm not
familiar with this paper i would love to see it if you find it and should there be a sequential
step of what you should be looking for i can't agree more there should like we have fast in our
head right like we know how to spell that we know what points of of care to do on the patient um i'm
not aware of something like that existing but i don't you know i i'm human yeah fair me too and i
can't feel life from your memory but i'll take another look and see if i can dig it up you you
find it and then uh we'll talk about it on on on part two yeah and you know maybe maybe there's
a reason why i can't find it maybe it's been redacted or something like that because it didn't
work out but i think we'll see that that could also be a thing because that does happen often
in medicine yeah cool well that's all the questions that i had for you i was curious
if there's anything else that you wanted to talk about um that i didn't bring up while we're here
i mean we touched on postpartum hemorrhage that's usually people's big number one
question when we're when we're discussing this as it should be and then we kind of talked about
the differences you know between midwives those are another big thing people love to know that i
did i did write an article and i included it in the links that you guys but i gave you this morning
but um yeah so i wrote an article if you want to if you want to talk more learn more about that and
i created an entire class called ems and midwives um navigating the out of hospital birth so i teach
that specifically to midwives and ems providers together at the same time and we run through how
to actually do calls together in case there ever does need to be a transfer that's a really
stinking fun class too so and then i also included a code for your listeners to get a discount on
workshops and if you go to my website which is combatmidwife.com there's a ton of free
info on there there's a plethora of fun things there's an open source book and a bunch of other
fun stuff and you also have links on your website to all the other podcasts you've been on as well
because i'm not the first to uh to recognize that you have a lot to offer here oh thank you yes so
on the publications page are all my free resources as well as uh not every podcast i've been on but
the the good ones the really the really good ones that i love um those those guys are on there
otherwise my i think my website lady would would hate me yeah understandable well cool i really
appreciate you taking the time to come on and yeah we'll have to do it again one of these days as i
think more questions perfect i i would love to come back and maybe we can get into the nitty-gritty of
um like actual calls you've been on and we can maybe dissect those that's also really fun to do
too so if you come at me with some calls perfect thanks thanks for having me so much i really
appreciate it ryan yeah for sure and that's pretty much it thanks for tuning in just before we hop
off here i just want to give a shout out to my friend josh pitman and his buddy kevin pons
they're the ones who put the music together for all of this catch you next time
so